on s'intéresse maintenant au sort des
polyakov ce couple de dresseurs d'ours
qui vise à chauvigny du perche
aujourd'hui il comparaissait devant le
tribunal de blois pour sévices graves
mauvais traitements et actes de cruauté
envers leurs trois ours en septembre
2019 les images des conditions de vie de
misha boni aigles achats avaient fait le
tour des réseaux sociaux est ému jusqu'à
la ministre elisabeth borne depuis ces
animaux ont été placés dans des refuges
mais l'un d'entre eux est mort résumé de
l'audience et de ses enjeux avec lucas
chopin alexandre poliakov s'est présenté
seul à la barre sans son épouse absente
pour raisons de santé
le montreur d'ours à qui l'on reproche
notamment la détention illégale
d'animaux sauvages comme des perroquets
ou un singe à nier en bloc toutes les
accusations de mauvais traitements sur
ces ours bruns j'ai fait le nécessaire
pour les soigner assure-t-il pour
l'avocat du couple la défense est
toujours restée la même
ils ne sont pas responsables du mauvais
état de santé des ours la ligne de
défense est là c'est simple il des
infractions qui sont purement matérielle
sur des animaux qu'on n'avait pas
forcément le droit de détenir des
oiseaux des singes là il est évident
qu'on va être obligé entre guillemets
commandes comme on le dit pas ces
condamnations
en revanche s'agissant des maltraitances
et des actes de cruauté les choses sont
très fermes de notre côté mon client
était innocent de l'effet des faits qui
lui sont reprochés
pourtant des images tournées par des
associations de protection animale hier
en 2019 montre un ours micha faible aux
griffes trop longues et aux pattes
infesté de verre pour l'avocate de
l'association one voice partie civile
dans le dossier il faut interdire aux
couples d'exercer une quelconque
activité avec des animaux puisque
l'association one voice espère bien
évidemment si
la confiscation de tous les animaux
voilà c'est il ne faut plus que
les exploitants détiennent un quelconque
animal parce qu'ils sont comme
imperméable à cette souffrance animale
et ils sont pas en capacité de gérer un
animal le jugement a été mise en
délibéré le couple risque jusqu'à deux
ans d'emprisonnement et 30 mille euros
damende pour l'exercice de sévices
graves sur ces sources